being the best-selling fiction author of
the 90s is a big deal
writing 41 books in an internationally
best-selling series is a big deal
being the most shoplifted english author
of all time
also a big deal by those metrics we
could say terry pratchett is three big
deals happening in the same trench coat
but he's actually far more complicated
than that as you're about to learn
as one of the first writers to make a
habit of using the internet to
communicate with their fans
we were able to draw from a wealth of
his news group posts to present you
with this unfiltered view of pratchett
from pratchett himself
[Music]
every discworld fan owes a debt of
gratitude to the librarians of the
beaconsfield public library
in buckinghamshire england for if they
hadn't stoked the curiosity
of a young terry pratchett he might
never have become a writer
born on april 28 1948 the only child of
a mechanic and a secretary he first
experienced adversity at the hands of
his peers and the crueler teachers
at hotspur school bullied for a speech
impediment pratchett spent as much time
as he could in the library
reading anything he got his hands on
when i was a kid i read dictionaries all
the way through
dictionaries thesauruses dictionaries of
slang all that sort of thing
for the sheer fun of doing it i think i
was a rather
weird kid to be frank another early
source of fine literature came from his
grandmother who would go on to inspire
one of his most famous characters
granny weatherwax i was allowed to read
from her bookshelf it was a very short
bookshelf but it contained every book
you really ought to read like the
complete short stories of h.g
wells and the complete short stories of
sir arthur conan doll i just worked my
way along my granny's bookshelf and
didn't realize
that i was getting an education he
published his first story at the age of
13 in his high school newspaper and
continued to publish throughout the next
few years the early taste of journalism
eventually motivated him to quit school
at 17 and pursue employment with the bux
free press where
he wrote a weekly column named
children's circle if you're curious
about
what his early work was like many of
those stories were later republished in
the collection dragons at crumbling
castle and other tales
featuring hilarious illustrations by
bark beech it's ideal for younger
readers or
established pratchett heads who enjoyed
the comedic atmosphere of the first
disco world novels
from his start in 1965 he worked
diligently until a chance encounter with
one of the publishers of colin smize
limited
in 1968. peter banda vandurum would
eventually become one of sir terry's
best friends though
neither of them could have imagined the
literary empire they would build when
they first sat down together for an
interview in the course of their
discussion pratchett mentioned a novel
he was working on which
peter asked to read and eventually
publish 1971 saw terry pratchett turn
23 and release his first novel the
carpet people if you haven't heard of it
you're not alone the first edition was
received well but
failed to generate a lot of press after
his work took off he eventually rewrote
a second edition
and in the forward joked this book had
two authors
and they were both the same person he
then followed it up with two sci-fi
novels darkseid of the sun in 1976 and
strata in 1981.
both the carpet people and strata focus
on flat planets a
central theme of the discworld series
1976 also saw the birth of his daughter
rihanna she would go on to write several
aaa video games like mirror's edge
prince of persia and bioshock infinite
she is also co-director of naretevia the
production company that handles
adaptations of sir terry's works
he would eventually leave journalism for
a position as a press officer with a
group of nuclear power plants just
four months after the three-mile island
scandal he often explains that decision
by making a joke about his impeccable
timing but
working so directly with nuclear
professionals clearly left an impression
about the importance of electricity and
how fragile the nation's infrastructure
really is
there's a particularly cutting quote
from good omens about the terse
relationship between the media
and nuclear energy it goes surely you
have considered terrorist activity
there was another pause then the
spokesman said in the quiet tones of
someone who has
had enough and who is going to quit
after this and
raise chicken somewhere yes i suppose we
must
all we need to do is find some
terrorists who are capable of taking an
entire nuclear reactor out of its can
while it's running and
without anyone noticing it weighs about
a thousand tons and is 40 feet high so
they'll be quite strong terrorists
perhaps you'd
like to ring them up sir and ask them
questions in that
supercilious accusery way of yours he
often said that he would write a book
about his experiences if he thought
anyone would believe them but sadly he
never did
his next big break came in 1983 with the
release of the first discworld book the
color of magic which placed 93rd in that
year's big read only 506 copies were
printed in the first run
making them hot commodities today one
signed and personalized book given to
the publisher's typesetter
has been valued at 27 000 less
sentimental copies generally fetch
prices north of a thousand dollars
the sequel the light fantastic came
three years later both of these stories
take place on the disc world a
flat planet carried on the backs of four
elephants who are standing on a giant
turtle flying through space
it serves as a sort of warehouse for
genre tropes there's
a wizarding school which is on
broomsticks werewolf cops high-speed
communication via an international
semaphore network dwarven
baking all your favorite sword and
sorcery standbys 1987 saw the release of
discworld novels three
and four equal rights and mort both of
which were smash hits and sold so well
that pratchett was able to quit his
press job and write novels full time
mort also represents the series's
departure from fast towards a more
nuanced relationship between the story
and the reader now 1971
to 1987 is a gap of 16 years pratchett
was working full time
raising a family and writing novels
simultaneously for 16 solid years before
he started selling well enough to focus
exclusively
on books for his living if you ever feel
discouraged about your own creative
endeavors
just know that the world slept on sir
terry pratchett's talent for a solid
16 years before giving him the respect
he deserved
but why is his work so successful well
let's take a closer look i mentioned
already that the discworld
is a fruitcake of genre fiction's best
love tropes managing to be
both loyal to its source material
without ever seeming cliche
pratchett's writing strikes the perfect
balance between self-aware parody
and enlightened satire he draws your
attention to fantasy's
fourth wall through digressive footnotes
often nestled two or three recursions
deep but
no matter how hard he leans he never
breaks he crafts worlds which are
consistent in their self-contained
absurdity by simply thinking logically
about things without a logical
explanation
he would be the first to tell you a lot
of the humor and possibly a lot of the
power in the discworld series
comes from thinking logically about
those things which we don't normally
think logically about
that we just accept take for example
rinse wine the wizard protagonist of the
first discworld novel he is unable to
learn any spells because early on in his
studies he
stumbled across an ancient tome and
infected himself with an intensely
powerful semi-sentient spell
that drives lesser charms out of his
mind fleeing in terror
magic is a living force and disc world
it lingers on in the environment after
it's used some spells will even cast
themselves in order to avert the death
of their host pratcher dances fantasy's
eternally lingering question of
if there are magical beings who can bend
reality to their will
why aren't they doing it all the time by
modeling them after real-world academics
and locking them in a series of petty
bureaucratic disputes whose
office politics thwart even the most
idealistic ambitions
because otherwise they turn into power
mad dictators and start hurling
fireballs at neighboring cities
at several points in the series he jokes
not doing any magic at all was the chief
task of wizards
ultimately pratchett finds a way of
grounding even the wildest elements of
fantasy in utterly human terms
death adopts a daughter the unfeeling
and purely logical auditors of reality
grow a body and
attempt to eat chocolate only for the
sensory experience to be so intense it
causes their heads to explode
if you take something that exists only
to follow logic and you
incarnate it in something as illogical
as a human body obviously it's going to
struggle to adapt and
that struggle between the innate
functional programming of the universe
and
our capability for thought and feeling
marks the central conflict
in most of his stories he knew that the
ultimate horizon of fantasy lay
not in the conjurations of his own mind
but the exploration
of what it means to be a human in a
world not
explicitly designed around humanity
while the first two books of the series
are sequential the rest of the series
shares
a loose chronology with books following
a rotating cast of recurring characters
you might have seen the watch a bbc
televised adaptation of the stories
surrounding sir samuel vimes and the
ank morpock city watch first introduced
in the eighth book
guards guards vimes is your archetypal
beat cop who
through sheer dogged loyalty to his city
accidentally becomes a duke
along the way he marries a woman who
runs a swamp dragon rescue
because it logically follows that a
world with dragon ownership will contain
irresponsible owners typical boy meets
girl with dragon's story
his characters manage to be both fully
realized while also frequently serving
as
a satire for some familiar archetypes
for example moist von lipwig is
a con artist who under the threat of
being hung a second time reforms banking
and the post office in the space of two
books
going postal and making money offer
fascinating insights into how
institutions get bogged down with
bureaucratic bloat
when they stop being accountable to the
people they serve there's also a helping
of murder mystery and corporate
espionage mixed in
pratchett is a devil of a writer to
summarize moist is a stand-in for every
outsider who's ever dreamed about
getting a chance to fix something from
the inside
he is in many ways a metaphor for how
institutional reform normalizes public
services
specifically in going postal a poorly
run privately owned communications
company is taken over and reformed by
the post office it made obsolete
in a parallel to the early development
of telephone lines
making money satirizes everything
economics from the development of paper
currency to the concept of inflation
these don't normally sound like rich
sources of comedy
but that never once stopped pratchett to
hear him say it fantasy potentially
gives you a lot of good metaphors to
consider
because most current affairs are only
ubiquitous
everlasting affairs which turn up again
and again in different disguises
throughout history
the conflicts in his books never feel
artificial or forced because
they're always grounded in the
inevitable stresses that arise when
society is forced to very suddenly adapt
to
a new way of doing things his characters
struggle against themselves because
they are trying to build mutually
incompatible worlds
not because one of them is evil and
that's what evil does modernity
versus tradition city slickers versus
honest country folk
the power of belief versus the
immutability of the world
death riding a motorcycle while playing
a scythe guitar
these are the eternal conflicts all
folklore is built upon
though the discworld is undeniably what
he's most famous for the work he himself
was proudest of was his 2008 young adult
novel
nation set in a low fantasy alternate
history it focuses on the struggles of
the younger fisherman mao and the secret
princess in exile erm intrude as they
cooperate to survive on a remote island
after a devastating tsunami it's sort of
a coming-of-age east meets west
post-apocalyptic buddy comedy about the
importance of cultural preservation
and the dangers of eurocentric
anthropology he described it as the best
book i have
or will ever write and that is by no
means an overstatement
pratchett brought the full strength of
his studies to bear everything he
learned about carnivorous plants by
growing them in his greenhouse it's in
here the book contains observations on
ecology the state of natural history
research in the 1800s and why spitting
into beer is crucial to fermentation
it's simply a struggle to describe such
a nuanced work and if you've never read
pratchett
you should absolutely start with nation
though pratchett himself said he
collaborated as well as a cat that
didn't stop him from teaming up with
well-known science writers jack cohen
and ian stewart on
the science of discworld a set of four
books which blend pratchett's fantasy
with hard science
framed as the result of a magical
experiment gone awry
the four books in the series explore the
interactions between the wizards of the
unseen academy
and the miraculous new universe full of
odd round planets that they accidentally
created
though it's framed as fantasy the
science it contains is
bedrock solid you will actually learn
something scientific from this book
about wizards
it's equal parts educational and
hilarious there's also good omens a
collaboration with best friend and
occasional inkslinger himself neil
gaiman
written in 1990 over long phone calls
and male floppy discs pratchett
described it as a rising from
the right person right subject right
time
the story is an examination of the
comedy of errors that results after the
newborn antichrist is switched with a
random baby and raised like a normal
child in the british suburbs
despite being written by two titans
famous for their
impressive narrative voices the work is
far greater than just the sum
of their commendable parts some passages
are clearly the fruit of just
one hand but most of the book blends
them together perfectly
to revel in the full playfulness of
language maybe you're not in the mood
for a novel about a potential apocalypse
right now given
everything going on but if you're
curious it was adapted into a bbc
miniseries that finished airing in
february of 2020.
[Music]
[Applause]
while he cultivated a twinkie-eyed jolly
persona in public pratchett's writing
was fueled by a deep-seated anger
in an interview with the guardian gaiman
shared a fascinating story
about encountering that anger on their
promotional tour for good omens
misreading an address they chose to
spend the time between interviews by
walking to the radio station for the
next appointment what they assumed would
be a short drawn on a level street
instead turned into a hike
of several miles of a rough terrain
pratchett grew furious while neal was
stumbling over how to assuage his friend
terry responded
do not underestimate this anger this
anger was the engine that powered good
omens
if you like e the writer the interview
is definitely worth a read
a few years before that story took place
in 1984 gaiman interviewed pratchett for
space voyage magazine it's mostly
unremarkable say for a casual offhand
claim by pratchett of having created the
world's first
talking door which is not a common boast
why the whole interview wasn't about
that fascinating tidbit escapes
explanation but pratchett would later
clarify in one of his frequent visits to
the alt-dot fan dot pratchett news group
that he rigged it out of a z80 computer
running speech synthesis software
and a circuit board harvested from a
chemical control plant it had about a
dozen random phrases including
you have entered a prohibited area
weapons deploy in 10 seconds and
creek creek creek which was my favorite
it's great fun to
look back in time to what the internet
was like before social media
and realize how little of it has
actually changed for not more than 10
posts after
terry weighed in with the answer the
conversation evolved into an argument
about an unrelated subject because
of course it did
a talking door is by no means the
coolest thing he ever created in his
life at 62 years of age he decided to
dig up several chunks of iron ore from a
field near his house and smelt them in a
makeshift kiln fired by sheep manure
and into this iron which would
eventually be made into a sword he added
several pieces
of literal meteorite you know space
metal the
kind that heroes use to slay villains
and why did the famous fantasy author
decide to make him a probably magic
sword fit for one of his own heroes well
that was because the queen knighted him
now pratcher would be the first person
in a conversation to downplay the scale
of his own success having once said
the reason i make the sales is that
everything i've written is in print
and still selling very well and every
new book adds to it
and the whole huge thing just keeps
rumbling onward but try
as he might eventually started
attracting the attention of the
gatekeepers of the literary
establishment
his first outright win was the 1990
british sci-fi association award for
pyramids a novel about a pyramid so
large it threw an entire country out of
time-space alignment his subsequent
works would go on to attract continued
attention frequently ranking high in the
locus awards
after two nominations in 2002 he finally
won the carnegie medal award for the
amazing maury send his educated rodents
the
discworld's response to the pied piper
of hamlin this was the first discworld
novel written specifically for younger
readers and
the carnegie would go on to become his
most treasured award due to the fact
that it was given to him by teachers and
librarians
people who could see firsthand the
impact that his work had on a young
audience
his acceptance speech is a must read
with brilliant observations on the
importance of humor and fantasy
like laughter can get through the
keyhole while seriousness is still
hammering on the door
new ideas can ride in on the back of a
joke old ideas
can be given an added edge that same
year i'd also have an asteroid named
after him
busy fellow he was one of the few men
ever listed in the amelia bloomer book
list for feminist writing with the 2004
tiffany aiken story the we free men
the aiken line of stories would go on to
become some of his most frequently
awarded
as i teased before in 1998 he was
designated an officer of the british
empire for his services to literature of
course he was humble about it writing to
ansible magazine
i suspect the services to literature
consisted of refraining from
trying to write any still i can't help
feeling mighty chuffed about it
in 2009 this was followed up with by a
full-on queen-officiated
knighting so of course he needed a sword
and of course it had to be made by him
with meteorites and england being as
they are with blades he had to hide it
from the constabulary
a hidden meteorite masterwork probably
magical sword owned by
a knight of the pen dungeon masters take
note
there's next week's plot hook courtesy
of terry pratchett's actual life
[Music]
2007 saw the release of discworld novel
making money which earned a nebula
nomination and won the locus award it
was also the year sir terry made public
his diagnosis
of posterior cortical atrophy a rare
form of alzheimer's disease that targets
the back of the brain
he would go on to donate a million
dollars to the alzheimer's research
trust and even volunteered his own body
for experimental treatments
he was public with his struggles in the
last few years of his life scaling back
his touring and
convention schedule and no longer
dedicating the books he signed for fans
in 2008 he recorded a two-part series
for the bbc
terry pratchett living with alzheimer's
it's an unflinching look at a brutal
disease
from an intensely unique perspective it
won a bafta reward and
drew in 2.6 million extremely ready to
be depressed viewers
as the disease progressed he began
advocating for assisted suicide saying
i believe it should be possible for
someone stricken with a serious and
ultimately fatal illness
to choose to die peacefully with medical
help rather than suffer if this topic is
upsetting to you you'll probably want to
skip forward a few minutes right now
until you see the next title screen
it was on that same subject he delivered
the 2010 bbc richard dimbleby lecture
shaking hands with death though he was
able to read the introduction
he left the body of the text to his
friend tony robinson the lecture is
as everything pratcher ever wrote
beautiful and moving
and full of profound insights but it's
not easy to watch someone you respect
grapple with the prospect of their own
imminent mortality he followed that up
the next year with another bbc
documentary terry pratchett
choosing to die it features terry
interviewing patients and employees of
the dignitas clinic and assisted suicide
institution in zurich switzerland
he also discusses the indignities of
terminal diseases and
his thoughts on mortality specifically
the prospect of ending his own life
you also witness on camera a patient
ingests a lethal amount of phenobarbital
it's a deeply upsetting scene and a very
important work and if you choose to seek
it out
know that you will see someone die it's
not light viewing
but if you want to understand how
assisted suicide works from the inside
out
there is no more thorough source
on march 12 2015 terry pratchett died of
natural causes
he was 66 years old survived by his wife
lynn
and his daughter rihanna this world 41
the shepherd's crown was released
posthumously on august 27th
it's the sixth tiffany aching story and
it's the last discworld novel that's
ever going to be released
according with pratchett's wishes his
hard drive was placed in the middle of a
street in the great dorset steam
festival
and flattened with a steamroller many
discworld fans have
mourned what they feel was lost with
that flattening including as many as 10
unfinished titles but those books
weren't ever real they never belonged to
anyone but pratchett
and he just wasn't ready to give them to
the world far too often the unfinished
works of a beloved author are polished
up by
a hired hand and sold to an audience of
mourners
we obviously don't need to name names
here but there's a reason they keep
remaking
the original dune who on earth is
qualified to fill so terry's shoes
who has his rage at the injustices of
the world his love
of human foibles his adoration of nature
he was
simply a once-in-a-generation talent and
we were lucky to get as many books out
of him as we did
41 disc worlds four science of
discworlds good omens
nation many others i didn't even mention
like the five
co-written titles in the long earth
series every single one of them an
exercise in the joy of imagination
terry took advantage of every day of
work his talent brought him
and he'd want us to do the same thanks
for the good times terry
and i really hope you found that video
interesting and inspirational if you did
please do hit that thumbs up button
below don't forget to subscribe
thank you for watching
you